hey it turns out that big shock Donald
Trump's majority Muslim country
immigration ban might be bad for tourism
to the United States and thus bad for
countless American businesses and the
employees of those businesses an
economic consulting company called
tourism economics has studied the
numbers from different airlines travel
booking websites and they are projecting
that because of the Trump Muslim
immigration travel ban the United States
will lose six point three million
foreign tourists by the end of next year
this would work out to just under eleven
billion dollars in tourist consumer
spending on average foreign tourists
visiting the United States spend about
four times as much as domestic tourists
foreign tourists are really really
important to the tourism economy this
could affect ninety thousand people
whose jobs rely on tourism Adam Sachs
the president of the research company
said quote it doesn't take very much
uncertainty or antipathy to influence
decisions away from a given travel
destination ultimately destinations and
companies are in the business of
building a brand and the message that is
welcoming all the America first rhetoric
in various policy areas like trade
diplomacy and immigration is conveying
the exact opposite absolutely true I was
thinking Pat of all the countries I
wouldn't travel to for political reasons
and sort of trying to separate myself if
I lived in Europe or you know
potentially like in Israel a Middle
Eastern country that's not impacted by
the travel ban and heard that the United
States was doing this even if I wouldn't
be directly affected by it because my
country of residence isn't on the list
I'd probably still start to harbor an
antipathy towards visiting the United
States as a tourist especially cuz you
don't ever know if the country that you
live in is going to be affected by a
future travel ban sure the initial one
was just rolled out all of a sudden no
one really had time to prepare for it
and I mean if you're planning a vacation
a year out in advance can you be certain
that that's not going to affect you you
would think that if you're in Italy you
can be relatively certain I guess but
who knows I mean in the Trump era it's
all crazy and the city's anticip
to lose the most foreign tourists or San
Francisco la Miami and of course New
York City this could cost New York City
over a billion dollars a flight searches
from the UK to Miami are down
Christopher Haywood the senior vice
president of NYC & Co the official
tourism marketing agency of New York
said quote people know that New York is
a city of immigrants that we pride
ourselves on diversity and tolerance but
Trump is also from New York so who knows
if that has created confusion this is
also impacting business travel just
since Trump signed the first Muslim
majority country immigration ban a
little over a month ago business travel
bookings to go to the United States are
down by nearly 200 million dollars
according to another study by tourism
economics Donald Trump is hurting the
American economy in new and novel ways
that you might not even have anticipated
does he get points for creativity here
that we predicted many ways in which
Trump would be bad for the economy he's
coming up with new ways to be bad for
the economy I mean I think he's made the
claim that he's going to be great for
jobs in manufacturing for example yeah
but I don't think he's ever claimed that
tourism is going to be his forte no he
certainly hasn't claimed that and he's
sticking to the lack of mentioning that
no doubt about it so not good news for
many many businesses not exactly big ly
tremendous is it I don't know I don't
think it falls under that umbrella